WELCOME.
THE HEARING OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE.
LIKE.
TO A WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOWER WHO IS FILLING IN FOR OUR
VACANCY TODAY [inaudible]
EXCELLENT REPLACEMENT.
WE'LL BE HEARING JUST ONE BELL
TODAY S. B. TWO TWELVE JACKSON.
AND AS SOON AS HE AUTHOR I. GETS
WILL --
PROCEED.
OUR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO STAB WISH QUORUM
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
HERE QUIRK IS HERE MELENDEZ
MULLIN DOES IS HERE OUT I'M
ALLOWED.
ARAMBULA IS HERE BRO
[inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
CALLER IS HERE MORE NOT SO CHEAP.
WE HAVE FOUR PEOPLE WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
OKAY FORMS PRESENT.
BOB WE'RE GOING --
TO JUST WAIT FOR A FEW MINUTES
TILL WE GET THE AUTHOR HERE
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH [inaudible]
THE LAST [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
STILL AHEAD COUNTY MEDICAL.
OKAY WHICH I DON'T OKAY
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
YEAH BUT MY COPIER FROM
[inaudible]
POLITICAL
.
WE STAY FOR AN HOUR.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
[inaudible]
CULTURE [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
WE'RE ROUGH.
THIS IS THE LAST WEEK OF SESSION
YES OF COURSE.
THEY WERE ALL STILL SEMI
STANDING SERVICES INCLUDING.
SO.
WE HAVE A QUORUM --
WORLD THANK YOU HEAR FROM YOU
SENATOR I KNOW YOU'VE DONE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK AS
HAVE YEAR.
CO AUTHORS --
OR JOINT.
PRINCIPLE COAUTHORS TING AND
GRAY.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU ALL FOR
ALL THE CLOSE ALL OF THE HARD
WORK YOU'VE DONE.
AND FOR ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE ROOM.
ARE BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS
YUVAL.
ARE GOT NEXT THE POINT WHERE WE
ARE NOW.
I AM EXTREMELY CONCERNED THAT WE
GET THIS TO THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
AND THE REASON IS WHETHER YOU'RE
FOR A TAKE BACK PROGRAM OR NOT.
WE CAN ALL AGREE HAVING. FORTY
DIFFERENT TAKE BACK PROGRAMS
HE'S NOT A GOOD IDEA I CAN ALSO
TELL YOU THAT SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE TERRIBLY
INEFFECTIVE AND THEN THE VARIOUS --
COUNTIES PARTICULARLY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WHICH WAS THE FIRST ONE
TO GO -- I
CAN'T TELL WELL.
I'VE LOOKED UP WHERE THEIR SITES
ARE IN THEIR NOT AVAIL NOT
REALLY EASILY AVAILABLE TO
ANYONE.
SO HELP ONE OF THE THINGS WE CAN
GET HERE IS --
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WORKS BETTER
WHERE PEOPLE KNOW WHERE THE
PICKUP SITES ARE HAVING A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
A BIG HELP IN THAT [inaudible]
AND SENATOR PLEASE PRESENT.
WELL THANK YOU KIND OF MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JUSTICE ARE OF
A BILL I BEEN WORKING ON FOR
QUITE SOMETIME AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT.
WHEN WE STARTED WE TRY TO GET
ALL THE STAKE HOLDERS IN THE
ROOM TOGETHER THAT ALONE WAS A
CHALLENGE --
BY THE END OF THE FIRST OUR I
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE TO
CALL.
A NINE ONE ONE BECAUSE WE COULD
NOT GET AGREEMENT ON ANYTHING.
AND SINCE SEPARATE OF TIME AS
YOU ARE INDICATED THERE ARE
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE CREATED THEIR OWN
PROGRAMS.
SO WE NOW HAVE A VERITABLE HODGE
PODGE [inaudible]
PROGRAMS --
I BELIEVE THAT I THINK --
EVERYONE WHO STEPPED UP BELIEVE
WE COULD GET TO YES ON THIS AND
SO.
THIS IS YES IT'S NOT A PERFECT
YES BUT IT I BELIEVE WILL --
MOVE US FORWARD TO CREATE
PROGRAMS THAT AS YOU INDICATE
ARE EFFECTIVE WHERE PEOPLE KNOW
WHERE THEY CAN GO WHERE PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE.
AND SO I'M VERY DELIGHTED --
A LITTLE SURPRISED BUT VERY
DELIGHTED WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
FINAL PRODUCT FOR YOU --
THIS WAS TRULY LIKE HERDING CATS
BUT BUT WE'RE ALL RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF COMING TO YES
TO AN AGREEMENT ON THIS POST
BOTH FOR DRUGS.
AND FOR SHARPS SO THAT WE CAN
GET RID OF THESE WE CAN DISPOSE
OF THEM AS SAFELY AS POSSIBLE
AND EFFECTIVELY SO.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT CREATES A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE PRODUCER
PAID TAKE BACK PROGRAM FOR HOME
GENERATED PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS.
AND MEDICAL SHARPS.
THE BILL WILL SET A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM UNDER WHICH CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
WILL BE ABLE TO SAFELY.
AND CONVENIENTLY AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT IF IT'S NOT CONVENIENT
THEY WON'T DO IT.
AND CONVENIENTLY DISPOSE OF
MEDICAL WASTE AN UNUSED MEDICAL
PRODUCTS GIVING SOLUTION TO A
PROBLEM THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
KNOW TOO WELL AND I WOULD SOON.
SUSPECT EACH AND EVERYONE OF US
IF WE'VE EVER IF YOU'VE
INDIVIDUALLY BEEN THROUGH A
HEALTH ISSUE YOU A FAMILY WHO'S
BEEN THROUGH IT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU'RE
LEFT WITH MEDICATIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN FULLY CONSUMED OR
THAT HAVE EXPIRED WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH THEM OR SHARPS OF OF THAT.
ARE OUT THERE AND POWER HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE DANGEROUS BY THE
VERY NATURE OF THEIR A BEING.
SO I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON RECENT
AMENDMENTS WHICH WERE TAKEN TO
ADDRESS AGENCY AND STAKEHOLDER
CONCERNS.
I FIRST WANT TO THANK GOD AS AS
THE CHAIRMEN CHURNED A STAFF OF
MY COLLEAGUES --
AN IN THE ASSEMBLY THIS HAS BEEN
A TRULY A A LABOR OF LOVE AND
WILL.
GET TO THIS RESULT AND WE HAVE
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE SITTING
WITH US TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM AND ALSO THANKED
STAFF -- WHO
WERE THROWN INTO THIS --
KERFUFFLE OF PROBABLY WITHOUT
REALIZING WHAT THEY HAD SIGNED
UP FOR SO THIS IS A BILL THAT --
ID.
THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THE
STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS AT THE
CHAIR HAD INDICATED WERE OF
CONCERN TO HIM SPECIFICALLY.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THE ROBUST
TIER DEFINITION OF WHAT A
COVERED MANUFACTURER IS.
WHICH HAS BEEN CRAFTED TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF NOT JUST
INDUSTRY BUT OF CAL RECYCLE AS
WELL.
WE'VE ALSO WORKED TO CREATE.
A WORKABLE FRAMEWORK TO HANDLE
THE SAFE AND COMPREHENSIVE TAKE
BACK ALL OF NEEDLES OF THE
SHARPS.
BOB BUT AUTHORIZING CAL RECYCLE
TO APPROVE A MAIL BACK A EXCUSE
ME BY AUTHORIZING CAL RECYCLE TO
PROVE A MAIL BACK.
BASED OF STEWARDSHIP PLAN THAT
FOCUSES ON READILY AVAILABLE
CONTAINERS.
THAT FREE OF CHARGE WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANY CONSUMER WHO
NEED SOME.
WE HAVE ALSO TAKEN ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE ALL
AGENCIES INVOLVED HAVE THE
AUTHORITY THEY NEED TO CONSULT
WITH ONE ANOTHER IT'S OFTEN
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING.
AND SOMETIMES I'M INCREDULOUS AT
THE FACT THAT THESE AGENCIES
DON'T EVEN THINK TO TALK WITH
EACH OTHER.
OR DON'T WANT TO TALK WITH EACH
OTHER SO WE HAVE ENCOURAGED IN
TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO GIVE THEM
THAT AUTHORITY.
WE'VE TAKEN SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
TO EXCLUDE SPECIALTY PRODUCTS OR
ANIMAL PRODUCTS WHICH ARE NOR
BEEN CONCERNED OTHER SEPARATELY
REGULATED BY OTHER AREAS OF
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
[inaudible]
AND THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT OF
MONTHS AND YEARS OF STAKEHOLDERS
COMING TOGETHER.
OF STRANGLING EACH OTHER COMING
BACK TOGETHER THIS IS BEEN.
A FAMILY FIGHT OF GREAT
PROPORTION BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE ALL RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING TO YES.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE PRINCE
MY PRINCIPAL COAUTHORS FOR THEIR
WORK AS WELL.
I THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
INVOLVEMENT ME TODAY AS JASON'S
SCHMELZER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE YET
HAIR.
AND AND RIGHT NOW I HE WILL --
BE HERE TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE AND WITH THAT
I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
TO THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
AVENUE HAVE BEEN RUN AROUND MY
HAIR ON FIRE THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED --
ALSO OBVIOUSLY WENT THINK --
THE TWO PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
PATTING IN GRAY I'M ALL THREE
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFFS --
WERE ABSOLUTELY VITAL THIS
PROCESS IN MISTER QUIRK.
ADDS CHAIRMAN I WOULD THINK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
LAST TIME WE WERE HERE --
I THINK WHAT IT DID IS IT GAVE
US THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO EXPAND THE CIRCLE SOMEONE.
AND REACH OUT AND TALK TO FOLKS
WHO STILL LIGHT ISSUES --
THAT WE NEEDED TO RESOLVE A AND
I'M I'M FAIRLY CERTAIN I THAT
WE'VE DONE THAT TO THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY.
ARE IN NO SMALL PART I WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF YOUR STAFF.
AND FOCUS ON THIS COMMITTEE SO
THANK ALL ATTRIBUTIONS TO ADD TO
THAT SUMMIT PUT MY EYES BACK ON
FOR SECOND VETO MIND --
A FEW NOTABLE CHANGES TO THE
BILL A ONE WEEK COMPLETELY
RESTRUCTURED THE SHARPS PORTION
THE BILL WE SAT DOWN WITH THE
INDUSTRY --
AND WE WORKED OUT SOMETHING
OTHER FRANKLY MAKES US ALL NOT
SUPER COMFORTABLE AB BUT WE FEEL
LIKE WE BOOTSTRAPPED IT --
WITH CERTAIN PROVISIONS ON OUR
SIDE A THEY SEEM TO BE MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT THEY'LL BE
HERE OBVIOUSLY TO TALK ABOUT IT
THEMSELVES.
ABOUT WE'VE WE'VE WE DID --
KIND OF OUT OF THE HOUSE BY THIS
COMMITTEE WE RECONSIDERED AND
RESTRUCTURE THAT PORTION OF THE
BILL NINE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE WITH THAT.
WE ENHANCE THE PROGRAM PROMOTION
OUT YOUR POINT EARLIER SO PEOPLE
KNOW ABOUT THE PROGRAM AT PEOPLE
KNOW WHERE TO FIND THE KIOSKS
PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO GET THEIR
MAIL BACK.
CONTAINERS AND WHERE TO SEND
THEM -- WE
HAVE DONE SIGNIFICANT TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP AGAIN IN NO SMALL PART
THANK YOU OUT TO YOUR TO YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AYE AND WE TOOK A HOST OF
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS OTHER
CONCERNS FROM OTHER FOLKS WE
HARMONIZE TIMELINES A WE DID A
LOT OF THINGS IN THE BILL --
THE BRING US TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY WHICH IS WITH A GOOD BILL.
OTHER TAKE A LOT OF WORK BY A
LOT PEOPLE --
THAT WILL HAVE A GREAT PUBLIC
IMPACT -- ON
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
LEVEL.
A PUBLIC HELP LEVEL
ENVIRONMENTAL LEVEL SO WITH THAT
CODE SIMPLY RESPECTFULLY URGE
DRIVE UP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HE I HAD
HAIR AND I HAD NO GREATER --
MY NAME IS OLIVER USE REGULAR.
PRETTY DARK HAIRED AYE IT'S AND
IS A FEW THERE'S A FEW THERE THE
RECENT.
UP ALL OF IRAQ OVER THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE UNIQUE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING BOTH
DRUG.
AND SHARP MANUFACTURERS AT THE
LAST TIME WE WERE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IN JUNE.
OUT WE HAD A POSITION THAT
REQUIRED SOME AMENDMENTS AND AND
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT IN THE
LAST -- SIX
TO EIGHT WEEKS THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR HER STAFF IN PARTICULAR
THE TWO PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
I AND THE WILLINGNESS OF NOT
ONLY THE INDUSTRY BUT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED --
TO REALLY MOVE THE BALL AND GET
TO A POSITION THAT WE COULD ALL
BE COMFORTABLE WITH.
NOT KNOWING THAT.
THERE ARE SOME CERTAINTIES IF
THIS BILL DOES --
THE CERTAINTIES INCLUDE LOCAL
ORDINANCES ADDITIONAL LOCAL
ORDINANCES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL --
SOME OF WHICH YOU'RE --
FORMER CONFUSING THAN THIS BILL
WE THINK A STATEWIDE PROGRAM
WITH AT LEAST TWO UNIFORMS HAD A
RULES --
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING PER THE
RECENT AGREE AMENDMENTS THAT A
DRUG AND A SHARPER DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS INNER --
TREATED DIFFERENTLY UNDER THIS
BILL --
THEREFORE WE'RE VERY HAPPY ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERSHIP TO URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO MOVE THE FOR
THE BILL TO THE FLOOR --
AND THEN TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO WITH
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY GOOD.
AUTUMN.
WELL I GUESS I LAST FOR OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FILL THE GRAVES OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS AND THEIR STAFFS.
FOR ALL THEIR TIME WORKING WITH
US WORKING TO ALL THE ISSUES
REPRESENT THE MEDICAL DEVICE
INDUSTRY IN THIS WE HAVE
REMAINING OBJECTIONS TO THE
LOCAL REIMBURSEMENT PIECE AND
SOME OF THE THAT WE'VE TECHNICAL
CONCERNS OF THE PROVISIONS OF
AYE SHARPS CONTAINMENT.
AT THE POINT OF SALE BUT WE ARE
REALLY REALLY PRETTY PLEASED
WITH THE COMPROMISE PRODUCT THAT
WE HAVE HERE TODAY.
AND URGE ALL OF YOU TO VOTE I TO
MOVE THE CONVERSATION OF THE
FLOOR THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS ADJUSTABLE ON
BEHALF OF TWO GROUPS THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECTIVES
AND THEY'VE BEEN LONGTIME
SUPPORTERS OF THIS IT'S WELL OF
IT YOU'D AND ALSO.
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE
WHICH I VOTE. THREE SEPARATE
RICH ON BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER
ACTION HILL THE BAND ALAMEDA
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SENATOR BEHALF THAT
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES THAT WE HAVE
MOVED OUR POSITION FROM OPPOSING
US AMENDED TO NEUTRAL --
VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK ON THE
AUTHORS AND THEIR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US I'M OUR MAIN
CONCERN AS CENTERED AROUND THAT
DEFINITION A COVERED ENTITY.
AND THE CONCERN OF HOW THAT
COULD IMPLICATE RETAIL
PHARMACIES OTHER LICENSES AND
ESPECIALLY PATIENT ACCESS TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND THE WAY
THAT WE COMPROMISE ON THAT --
DEFINITION I WE CAN'T SAY THAT
WERE.
STILL WILL BE INTERESTED TO SEE
HOW THE REGULATORY PROCESS --
LOOKS TO IMPLEMENT THAT
DEFINITION COVERED ENTITY ABOUT
IT FOR NOW WE ARE AND WE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH A NEUTRAL
POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH COUNTY CYCLE AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS ON IMPLEMENTATION SO WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BECOMING A THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VIA
SUPPORTING CONCEPT ON THE BILL
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHORS WHILE
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND SPONSOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS
OVER THE PAST COUPLE.
NICOLE WARD ALMOND ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
CHECK HELD IT ON BEHALF OF OUR
PUBLIC SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MELISSA M. ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL SEARCH ACTION COUNCIL
THE SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF
NORTH AMERICA AND THE WEST
IMPOSTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
AFTER JASON BROUGHT UP AT THE
WESTERN UNITED DAIRY MEN
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK --
TO GREAT CLARITY FOR AND WIDER
CULTURE WE ARE SUPPORT BILL
THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
JUST NOT FEEL THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION FOR
REASONS STATED BY MISTER BRYANT
APPRECIATE THE OTHER ADDRESSING
CONCERNS RELATED AND LIKE
CULTURAL WE AREN'T SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAN I CHANGE IT DENNIS ALVY
HONEY ON THE OTHER CALIFORNIA
GREEN FEET INSISTED CALVET
FARMERS WE ALSO.
RETURN MEMBERS SYLVIA'S SOLELY
SEAN BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTIES OF
BUTTE.
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO AND SHASTA
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA THINKING.
MARY PITY ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE OFTEN BE UP THE
CITY THE PASADENA STOCKTON
SACRAMENTO ALL IN SUPPORT.
CARE MEARNS IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AARON EVANS ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE EVANS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
NICK OFFICE OF CALIFORNIANS
HINTS HUESO STRONG SUPPORT.
TENNESSEE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THINKING.
IT'S YOU'RE MEMBERS ALEX AUTHOR
OF CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE DID HAVE AN
OPPOSING LESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL.
I'M WE ASK FOR HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS TO BE REMOVED BECAUSE OF
THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES OF MANY
OF THEM AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT WILL BE MOVING
OPPOSITION.
MAYBE SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES NEXT
YEAR TO WORK OUT AND OBVIOUSLY
MY MEMBERS ARE IMPORTANT AB
PARTS OF COMMUNITIES IN A PLACE
OF ALSO REMOVING OPPOSITION
AFFORD TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION NEXT YEAR.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION CENTER FOR
OCEANIC AWARENESS RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION PLASTIC POLLUTION
COALITION SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISERS AND THE FIVE TEARS
INSTITUTE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
OUR SHOW ALL NOTE THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WANTING --
TO WORK ON ADDITIONAL AND I AM
SURE WE WILL HAVE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WANT TO WORK
ON THIS DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT BEFORE I ASK FOR OPPOSITION --
MADAME CERTAINLY THEIR AUTHOR
THERE'S NO DOUBT NOW THAT MY TWO
OF PRINCIPLE CO AUTHORS ARE HERE
AND THEY CAN CERTAINLY FEEL FREE
TO PIPE AND I'M SURE WE'RE GOING
TO BE TWEAKING THIS FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME.
THE KEY IS BEEN OPENING THE
STORE.
WE HAVE AN AMAZING --
GROUP OFTEN DISPARATE --
SOURCES WHO HAVE COME TOGETHER
IN SUPPORT OF THIS IS THIS IS A
THE FIRST STEP IT'S A BIG FIRST
STEP BUT IT IS A FIRST STEP AND
I ANTICIPATE WILL BE HEARING AND
AND HAVING TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
GOING FORWARD DEATH.
IN THE FUTURE IT WILL BE THE
FIRST TIME WITH LEGISLATION THAT
REALLY MOVES THE NEEDLE.
UP BUT I'M LITERALLY AND
FIGURATIVELY I GUESS THAT WAS A
BAD PUN UP BUT I I DO THINK THAT
THIS IS A OF REALLY AM VERY
MAJOR AND A VERY POSITIVE STEP
FORWARD.
ALRIGHT UP BEFORE I ASK FOR
OPPOSITION ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY WOULD
YOU.
SAY A WORD OR TWO CERTAINLY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
MEMBERS LIKE TO THANK THE
PRINCIPLE [inaudible]
CO AUTHORS. FOR THEIR WORK CAN
GET TO THIS POINT OF THIS
ISSUE'S BEEN --
BEFORE THE LAST LEGISLATURE THE
ENTIRE EIGHTEEN YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN AROUND THE STATE CAPITAL
AND SO COMING TO SOME OF THE
MOVEMENT IN SOLUTION GOING
FORWARD IS IS QUITE A
ACCOMPLISHMENT WHICH SHOULDN'T.
A UNDERSTATE DATIN CERTAINLY FOR
EVERY GRIPE YOU KNOW IN THIS
BILL THERE'S A WIN --
IT REQUIRED US TO PUT ASIDE.
YOU KNOW KIND OF THE APPROACH
THAT WE OFTEN TOO OFTEN TAKE
CARE OF TO OF IDEOLOGICAL PURITY.
AND RATHER SIT DOWN AND ACTUALLY
NEGOTIATE COMPROMISE AND BRING
LEGISLATORS TOGETHER WHO BRING
OUT AT DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW.
A AND PERSPECTIVES AND AND DO
THE LONG MEETINGS AND AND OVER A
COUPLE YEARSFRANKLY --
WE WERE ABLE TO COME. TO A PLACE
WHERE I THINK THERE'S CERTAINLY
A LOT MORE GOOD THERE MAY BE
SOME YOU KNOW REMAINING
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS GOING FORWARD I
CERTAINLY AM COMMITTED.
TO ENSURING THAT THAT WE WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND OTHERS TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND I THINK
COUNT MY PRETZEL COAUTHORS OURS
WELL SO THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION TODAY.
THANK YOU THAT NOTHING THAT WE
JUST THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOUR
YOUR STAFF ARE MY MY STAFF
ANOTHER SENATOR STAFF --
MISTER GRAY'S STAFF I KNOW THEY
PUT IN.
ARM HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS
WHICH IS WHAT IT TOOK TO GET
THIS ON THIS PIECE LEGISLATION
DODD THEY DID AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
I THINK IS MISTER GRAY SAID THAT
THAT THIS ISSUE'S BEEN AROUND
FOR QUITE AWHILE BUT IT TOOK.
IN OUR COLLECTIVE STAFFS TO
REALLY BRING ALL THE TOGETHER TO
GET THIS.
THE PLACE THAT YOU CAN SEE WHAT
THIS FAIRLY EXTRAORDINARY PLACE
WILL BE HAPPY.
ON A GOVERNMENT'S NOT ONLY
GOVERNMENTS BUT GOVERNMENTS THAT
DON'T REALLY ALL ARE NECESSARY
LINE TOGETHER AGREEING YOU HAVE
INDUSTRY AGREEING.
ON YOU HAVE --
INDUSTRIES THAT TRADITIONALLY
HAVE BEEN VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO
THESE TYPES OF MEASURES FOR THE
KIND OF COMING TOGETHER.
IN A COMMON SOLUTION AND DISS
FOR FOR ME THE CULMINATION OF
THREE THREE YEARS WORK ON A
LONGER FOR THE SENATOR ALONG
WITH MR GRAPE I THINK IT'S
AMAZING THAT.
WERE ABLE TO GET TO THIS POINT
SO I JUST PERSON WANT TO THANK
ALL OUR STAFFS AT THINK AGAIN.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF HERE FOR
REALLY I GET IN THIS ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU AND I'VE HEARD
FROM STAKEHOLDERS.
BOB HOW IMPORTANT THE WORK OF MY
CHIEF CONSULTANT HAS BANNED --
EVEN AFTER THE FIRST SET OF
AMENDMENTS --
GOING THROUGH IT LINE BY LINE TO
FIND --
OTHER THINGS THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDED IN.
I I REALLY WANT TO THANK MY
CHIEF CONSULTANT VERY MUCH FOR
ALL HIS HARD WORK.
ALRIGHT WE NOW NEED TO HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION.
IT'S FINE YOU NOW WE ALL WHERE
THERE WERE HERE TO DO OUR JOBS
[inaudible]
DO YOU.
BUT NO ONE WITH A KNIFE THAT
BACK THERE ON NO THAT'S A THAT'S
RESERVED OVER THERE.
UP CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY CONCURRENT WOULD YOU
INTRODUCE YOURSELF OFF SORRY
ABOUT THAT UPRIGHT MICHELIN WITH
THE ASSOCIATION FOR ACCESSIBLE
MEDICINES --
THE AM REPRESENTS THE GENERIC
AND BIO PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURERS.
I AND AND WE WANTED TO START
WITH THE FACT THAT YES YOUR
STAFF'S A COMBINED HAVE DONE AN
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF WORK AND AND
THAT CERTAINLY APPRECIATED --
THE CONCERNS THAT A. M. HOUSE IS
BASED ON THE FACT THAT GENERIC
PHARMACEUTICALS I'M AND I'M
PRIMARILY GOING TO BE ADDRESSING --
THE THE PHARMACEUTICAL SIDE NOT
NECESSARILY THE SHARP SIDE --
NAM.
SINCE THOSE BUILT THOSE PORTIONS
WERE US SOMEWHAT SEPARATED AB
GENERICS HAVE SAVED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ALONE -- TO
HUNT OR TWO POINT.
BUT ARE TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S THROUGHOUT THE MEDICAID
SYSTEM THE MEDICARE SYSTEM.
CASH PAYING PATIENTS AND
COMMERCIALLY INSURED PATIENTS.
THE UNFORTUNATE FACT THIS BILL
IS THAT.
GENERIC MANUFACTURERS ARE GOING
TO BE PRIMARILY PAYING FOR THE
COSTS OF WHAT IS A VERY BROAD.
VERY PRESCRIPTIVE BILL
[inaudible]
AND THAT.
LIKELY WILL HAVE THE RESULT OF
INCREASING THE COST OF WATER
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE AND HAS
PROVEN OVER THE LAST?
A DECADE A DEPRECIATING MARKET
AND ONE OF THE ONLY DEPRECIATING
MARKETS WITH AND HEALTH CARE.
GENERICS OF DEPRECIATED 7%
[inaudible]
ANNUALLY.
THIS BILL HAS THE EFFECT OF
REVERSING THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
REVERSING THAT TREND.
ANA AND DEFINITELY SLOWING THAT
TREND.
WE HAVE REQUESTED TWO SEPARATE
SETS -- TO
AMENDMENTS --
THAT WE THINK WOULD HELP ADDRESS
COSTS IN THE BILL [inaudible]
BOTH. TO HELP*.
SPREAD THE COSTS THE OPERATIONAL
AND PROGRAMMATIC COSTS ACROSS
THE SUPPLY CHAIN [inaudible]
GENERICS --
GENERICS IN THIS BILL ARE
REQUIRED TO COVER THE COSTS FOR
ESSENTIALLY INNING COVERED
ENTITY THAT WISHES TO JOIN.
EVEN WANT TO PROGRAM'S BEEN
APPROVED AND ANNUALLY BY CAL
RECYCLE.
ANY COVERED ENTITY IS ABLE TO
COME AND REQUEST TO BECOME PART
OF SENATOR THE PROGRAMS.
THAT MEANS ENTITIES SUCH AS
WALMART CVS.
ANY OTHER LARGE CHAIN DRUGSTORE
WHICH ARE SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER
CORPORATIONS THE MOST GENERIC
MANUFACTURERS.
CAN BECOME PART OF THE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
WITH.
THE ENTITIES PAYING FOR THE
PROGRAM COVERING THOSE COSTS AS
WELL.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE.
GENERICS RIGHT NOW WHEN WRITTEN --
DISCUSSING THE SUPPLY CHAIN
RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD
OF THE REVENUE --
OF TIME THAT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
OF DRUGS MEANS THOSE OTHER
ENTITIES THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
COVERING COSTS FOR ARE TAKING
TWO THIRDS OF THE REVENUE.
THAT THIS BILL IS REQUIRING US
TO COVER THE ENTIRE COSTS AGAIN.
THE SECOND ASPECT THAT WE'VE LA
DISK DISCUSSED ANNA AND WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO HAVE SEEN COVERED
IN THE BILL.
IS THE FACT THAT.
THERE IS NO --
DEFINITION OF ORDER OR NON
ACCEPTANCE OF REVENUE VERSES
VOLUME IN IN THE BILL.
GENERICS AGAIN TWENTY THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS SAVED.
IN ONE YEAR ALONE.
THIS BILL IGNORES ANY
CONSIDERATION OF REVENUE.
WE WOULD REQUEST THAT.
THERE BE SOMETHING THAT REQUIRES
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS --
THAT REVENUE VERSUS VOLUME BE
ADDRESSED --
IN THE AMOUNT OF OF OF HOW THESE
COSTS ARE BEING A I'D
DISTRIBUTED.
CURRENTLY THERE IS ONE PROGRAM.
THAT'S IN EXISTENCE ASIDE PAT WE
WE WERE PART OF ADMITTEDLY PART
OF OF STARTING --
BUT THAT PROGRAM ALSO.
DIVIDE COST BASED ON VOLUME NOT
ON REVENUE.
GENERICS ARE 90% OF WHAT IS
PRESCRIBED IN THE STATE
[inaudible]
AND NATIONALLY.
THAT WE TAKE 23% OF THE REVENUE
[inaudible]
BRAND MANUFACTURERS.
ON THE FLIP SIDE.
OR 10% OF WHAT'S PRESCRIBED
INTAKE 77% OF THE REVENUE.
THAT THIS BILL.
AND THE PROGRAMS THAT EXIST
WOULD.
BUT BECAUSE PRIMARILY ON ON
GENERIC MANUFACTURERS.
IN THE ANALYSIS THIS BILL COULD
YOU TAKE ABOUT ONE MORE MINUTE
YOU'VE GOT ABOUT SOLELY ON HER
JUST ABOUT DONE OKAY --
ONE I IN THE ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL IT TALKS ABOUT THE
INCREASING COST OF DRUGS --
AS ONE OF THE SCOPES OF NEED FOR
THIS BILL.
OUGHT TO SHOW THAT THE AMOUNT OF
DRUGS OUT THERE ARE GOING UP.
YET THE BILL COMPLETELY IGNORES
THE COST OF DRUGS.
AND THE LOWER COST DRUGS NGUYEN.
THE PROGRAMS ARE BEING ASKED THE
PAID.
FOR THERE ARE OTHER WAYS OF
ACHIEVING SOME THIS [inaudible]
EDUCATION.
OF BOTH PRESCRIBERS AND PATIENTS
PATIENTS SHOULD BE TAKING THE
DRUGS THAT ARE PRESCRIBED
[inaudible]
DESCRIBE FIRST SHOULD NOT BE
OVER PRESCRIBING.
A PRETTY BASIC FACT.
WE BELIEVE THROUGH BETTER
EDUCATION AND BETTER KNOWLEDGE
BETTER --
THAT IT HEREIN ARE.
RECOGNIZING THAT CAL RECYCLING
ALREADY HAS IN THERE ARE OVER.
SIX HUNDRED THINK BACK CENTERS
ALREADY IN THE STATE EXPANDING
THOSE SHOULD BE DONE EXPANDING
KNOWLEDGE OF THOSE.
SHOULD BE DONE.
BUT HAVING AN OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE.
AND VERY --
BURDEN SLIM BILL FOCUS PRIMARILY
AT GENERIC MANUFACTURERS WE
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S APPROPRIATE
AND THOSE ARE THE REASONS THAT
WE ARE IN A ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
BUT STILL OFFICIALLY IN AND
OPPOSE ENLISTMENT.
POSITION THANK YOU.
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'VE
MADE YOUR POINT VERY CLEAR OTHER.
NEXT SPEAKER.
THINK THAT YOU TRY TO KEEP IT TO
FIVE MINUTES --
THINKS IT'S QUIRK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LEO AND I'M
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
HEALTH CARE DISTRIBUTION
ALLIANCE --
WORD A TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING PRIMARY
PHARMACEUTICAL WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS ESSENTIALLY OUR
ROLE IS TO ENSURE THE SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND HOSPITALS PHARMACIES
AND POINTS OF CARE HAVE.
ODD SAFE AND TIMELY ACCESS TO
THE MEDICATIONS THEY NEED TO
TREAT THEIR PATIENTS.
I'M WE ARE HERE AND PARTIALLY IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO
SENATE BILL.
TWO TWELVE AND HDMI MEMBER
COMPANIES REALLY STAND READY TO
WORK WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN
PARTNERS AND GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
ENSURING THAT THERE IS A SAFE
AND SECURE WAY TO DISPOSE OF
UNWANTED MEDICATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE ONGOING WORK
OF THE SPONSORS AND THEIR STAFF
AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR HELPING AT THE BILL WHERE IT
IS TODAY.
I BUT WE DO HAVE OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE --
BASED ON ESSENTIALLY THE
AMBIGUOUS DEFINITIONS ENTAILED
AN UNFETTERED REGULATORY PROCESS.
IN THE CURRENT DEFINITION
LANGUAGE --
COVERED ENTITY PROVIDES A VAGUE
DEFINITION AND REQUIRING SEVERAL
ENTITIES TO POTENTIALLY BE
LIABLE FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND THE LANGUAGE DOES NOT OFFER
DEFINITIONS TO MANUFACTURER --
NOR DOES IT PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON
WHAT.
BUT QUALIFIES ITS OWN BEING IN
THE STATE [inaudible]
I THAT'S AN AREA COULD RESULT IN
AN EFFICIENT WAY OF RAISING
REVENUE AND ULTIMATELY AT
UNNECESSARY COSTS TO THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
I WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE WAS ADDED TO REQUIRE
REGULATORY PROCESS TO ESTABLISH
PARAMETERS --
AROUND THAT DEFINITION BUT WE
BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ON HOW THE
DEPARTMENT WILL ENFORCE THAT
TIER DEFINITION.
BOTH PHARMACEUTICAL SUPPLY CHAIN
IS VASTLY DIFFERENT FROM ANY
OTHER INDUSTRY CURRENTLY
OPERATING A US STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM WITHIN THE STATE.
IT'S ONE OF THE HOPE MOST HIGHLY
REGULATED INDUSTRIES SO THERE
ARE OF DIFFERENT ISSUES
DEPENDING ON WHICH INDUSTRY THAT
THE COVERS I WAS WORKING ON AND
ULTIMATELY WHOLESALER
DISTRIBUTORS AND OTHER ENTITIES
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
ABU FACILITATE THE DELIVERY OF
PRODUCTS SHOULD NOT BE PENALIZED
FOR NON COMPLIANCE OF THE ACTUAL
MANUFACTURER.
OF NOR UTILIZED AS AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE.
I HATE SEEING OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES STAND READY TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH CALPERS
CYCLE ON THE REGULATORY PROCESS
AS WELL AS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS PROGRAM IT'S
VIABLE FOR THE STATE. TO THINK
IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A WHAT SORT
OF COMPANIES ARE MEMBERS OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION.
SIR I'M WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTORS
SO WE HAVE OUR ARE OKAY YOU.
GOT IT THANK YOU ABSOLUTE.
OR ARM OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ARM SO NOW WE GO TO THE
COMMITTEE --
ANY QUESTIONS --
MADAM VICE CHAIR NOW --
MR PEROT.
I HAD TAKEN THIS CHAIR.
YEAH FIRST SENATOR AND MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS SIDE OF THE
HOUSE --
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO GET TO AN
AGREEMENT ON THIS BILL.
UP COUPLE COMMENTS IN A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS SO FIRST MY HOME
THE DATA POINT WHERE PROGRAM --
THERE'S A BOX AT CITY HALL OF
THAT FOLKS.
CAN DROP OFF --
SCRIPT PROBLEM NEEDLES AND USE
DRUGS AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND
THEN A DEPUTY SHERIFF WILL TAKE
IN THE SAND AND THEN ULTIMATELY
TO LONG BEACH BE INCINERATED.
AND THE CITY'S ROLE IS TO ONE
PROVIDE A PLACE BUT TO MARKET IT.
TO GET THE INFORMATION OUT --
THE SO THAT'S THE WAY WE DO IT
LOCALLY BUT MY ONE QUESTION IS --
SINCE WE'RE DEALING WITH --
NEEDLES AND PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
Y. CAL RECYCLE MAYBE MORE
MEDICAL BOARD MIGHT BE A PROPER
PLACE TO COME UP WITH THESE
REGULATIONS WHY WAS CAL RECYCLE
CHOSEN.
WELL CAO RECYCLE ACTUALLY HAS
BEEN DOING RECYCLING PROGRAM SO
THEY ARE THE MOST LOGICAL.
OF ON THE GROUND JUST LIKE IT
COULD WE HAVE YOUR EXPERTS COME
UP HERE IN WITH --
SAY WE NEED TO TO GET ANOTHER
CHAIR BUT MISTER SCHMELZER.
AND SURE.
BUT I CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
YOU YOU CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAD
SOME OF YOUR EXPERTS APPEAR.
MR TINGS AN EXPERT.
SO CAL CAL RECYCLE IS.
IN CALIFORNIA THE FOREMOST
EXPERT ON OF THIS KIND OF
RESPONSE FIAMME PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY WE DO.
ON KANSEN CLASS AND ALL THIS
KIND OF THING AND IF YOU JUST
SUBSTITUTE.
A SHARP SHOULDN'T BECAUSE DRUGS
OBVIOUSLY THE GOAL IS TO
ADEQUATELY DISPOSE OF THESE
PRODUCTS THEY ARE THE MOST THEY
ARE THE EXPERTS IN THIS
PARTICULAR FIELD.
ARM OUT WE'VE WORKED WITH THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THEY ARE ALSO.
A VERY INTEGRALLY INVOLVED IN
THIS WHOLE PROCESS SO CAL
RECYCLE THEIR THE EXPERTS IN
THIS IN THIS AREA AND TO WORKING
WITH AS YOU MENTION MEDICAL --
GROUPS OF DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BOARD OF PHARMACY ARE
THE SORT OF THE I GUESS THE
SPECIFIC EXPERTS CAL RECYCLED
KNOWS HOW TO DO THIS KIND OF A
MANAGEMENT OF OF OF UNUSED.
AND AND THE NEED TO A DISPOSAL
THEM SAFELY IN AN APPROPRIATELY
FOCA DOES MY CONCERN THAT THE
SOME OF THE MEDICAL EXPERTISE
BECAUSE THESE ARE YOU KNOW
PLASTIC BOTTLES ALUMINUM CAN
PRINT.
AND FRANKLY CALORIE CYCLE I
THINK YOU KNOW ALL MY PLACES ARE
CLOSE WE CAN IN TURN IN THE CAN
SO.
SUBTLE LITTLE CONCERN THERE UP
MY SECOND QUESTION MIGHT SECOND
FINAL QUESTION IS A WAS ACTUALLY
FOR MR TING ON SOME FOLKS.
AND DESCRIBED THE ISSUE YOU HAVE
IN SAN FRANCISCO --
WITH NEEDLES [inaudible]
AND IT IS YOUR IS YOUR SITUATION
A MEDICAL SITUATION OR IS IT
FOLKS THAT ARE USING ILLEGAL
DRUGS AND THROWING THE NEEDLES
ON THE SIDEWALK AND THINGS LIKE
THAT YOU KNOW I I DON'T HAVE
EXACT DATA BUT IF I HAD --
ON I GUESS IT IS MORE --
PEOPLE WHO ARE --
GIVEN NEEDLES AND THEN NOT
DISPOSING THEM --
PROPER THE PUBLIC BE MORE THE
LATTER RIGHT IT'S I THINK THAT'S
WHY I'M.
HE WAS AGREED UPON TO DO A MAIL
BACK PROGRAM WAS SHARPS.
OBVIOUSLY --
SO FAR ARE PARTICULAR EXAMPLE
WHICH IS HOW I GOT INVOLVED IN
THIS ISSUE IT'S NOT JUST ON
MAILING BACK THE SHARP BUT
REALLY A LOT MORE EDUCATION.
AND HAVING A LOT MORE SITES FOR
PEOPLE TO DISPOSE OF THIS BECOME
PART UP QUITE ISSUE IS A BET NOW
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TOLD --
THE CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE ASKING
PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANIES YOU
KNOW TO PAY.
FOR DRUG USERS NEEDLES THAT ARE
NOT PLEASE.
THIS WILL BE IMPROPER BUT THAT'S
THAT'S CONCERNED QUOTE ME YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW
MAYBE.
AREN'T STOP SIGN SCREEN BOX ON
STOP SIGNS OR THINGS LIKE THAT
BUT NO I LOVE TO WORK WITH ME ON
THIS AND I THINK I THINK ARM I
THINK THAT'S A APPOINT WILL TAKE
AND THAT'S WHY WE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY.
ON WITH INDUSTRY FOR OVER THREE
YEARS TO REACH THIS POINT OUR
FARM.
I PRODUCE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
WE'VE WE'VE GOT INDUSTRY --
BY IN ON THAT BUT A BE OBSOLETE
RIGHT.
THAT WE DO NEED TO BE A MORE.
THIS TYPE OF PRODUCT OFF THE
STREET I KNOW OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAS A NUMBER OF
PLACES WHERE SHARPS CAN BE --
DISPOSE BUT YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES
YOU HAVE JUST.
IMPROPER HUMAN BEHAVIOR LITTLE
THEN THE NOCTURNAL WALK THE
EXTRA TWO BOXERS COUPON THE
STREETLIGHTS WERE SO THAT THAT'S
THE BIGGER ISSUE WITH SELF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BOB.
THEN THE DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND
THEN --
MISSED MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I WANTED TO START BY THANKING
THE AUTHOR FOR HEARING LOSS IN
THE LAST COMMITTEE HEARING AND
IT'S MAKING AMENDMENTS THAT MANY
OF US WERE ASKING --
FOR TYPE SPECIFICALLY I'M QUITE
A EXCITED ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
REMOVING AGRICULTURE FROM THIS
BILL JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR DOING IT.
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS BILL
TODAY MISTER CHAIR WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE GO AHEAD I MOVE
THIS BILL.
BUT I DO WANT SECONDS.
I DO WANT TO RAISE A CONCERN IF
I CAN.
I AM CURRENTLY WERE FACING SOME
MEDICAL SHORTAGES.
INABILITY TO RECEIVE CERTAIN
MEDICATIONS INTO CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES.
I HOPE THAT ADDING MORE
REGULATORY BURDEN WILL NOT
EXACERBATE THAT PROBLEM AND WILL
BE LOOKING TOWARDS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO ACCESS
GENERICS AND BRAND NAME
PHARMACEUTICALS ARE THINGS THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE.
WHILE I APPRECIATE THE SCOPE AND
SEVERITY OF THIS PROBLEM AND THE
NEED FOR THIS FIX THIS YEAR.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AS
WE IMPLEMENT THIS THAT WERE.
NOT FORGETTING THAT AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE PRESCRIPTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE FILLED AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK THE AUTHOR AND
CO AUTHORS FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO ITS
IMPLEMENTATION.
MERIT.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THAT.
THE BILL MOVING FORWARD --
TO BUT I WANTED.
TO NO RACISM --
ONGOING CONCERNS I HAVE --
SPECIFICALLY.
ARE THE DEFINITION OF COVERED
ENTITY IN THE BILL --
IT IT SEEMS TO BE --
A RATHER BROAD AND AND IT IT HAS
TO PROVISIONS ACCORDING TO
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OF A YOU KNOW
A COVERED ENTITY IF IF THERE'S
NOT A MANUFACTURER FOR COVERED
PROJECT.
A PRODUCT IN THE COVERED ENTITY
WOULD BE THE DISTRIBUTOR OF THE
COVERED PRODUCT SOLD INTO THE
STATE AND DOWN.
YOU KNOW AGE IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THAT THE THAT --
YOU KNOW THE BASIC.
EP OUR PRINCIPLES SAID THAT IT
SHOULD BE THE MANUFACTURE RATHER
THE DISTRIBUTOR THAT THAT WOULD
BE HELD THE LIABLE FOR A ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE YEAR --
IT'D THIS SIR EFFORT BUT TAG
WANTED ASK [inaudible]
SENATE JACKSON.
WELL I I CERTAINLY AGREE THAT IT
SHOULD BE THE MANUFACTURE
PRACTICALLY SPEAKING SOME OF
THESE MEDICATIONS AREN'T.
MADE HERE AND TO GO AFTER THEM
IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT IN A PART
OF THIS AND AND TO RESPOND AND I
APPRECIATE DR ROMULUS.
CONCERN OF THE BILL ALSO DOES
CALL FOR OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS MAY VERY WELL BE ABLE --
TO OR MAY STILL NOT BE ABLE TO
DISCERN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE COST SHARE BURDENS ON
DIFFERENT MANUFACTURERS.
BY AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
ACCORDINGLY SO IT IS OUR OUR OUR
HOPE THAT AS THIS.
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD AND WE SEE
HOW THIS ALL COMES TOGETHER THAT
THERE BE THAT SENSE OF EQUITY
AND THERE BE THAT SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY ME WE ARE TRUE
THIS IS TRULY A TRANSFORMATIVE.
UP BILL ON DEALING WITH
PHARMACEUTICALS AND SHARKS I
MEAN THAT THERE IS NEVER BEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS SO WE ARE WE
HAVE TRIED TO ANTICIPATE A LOT
OF THOSE PROBLEMS.
AYE AND A RESPONDBUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE FIGURED IT ALL
OUT AND WHAT WE TRIED TO DO WAS
KEEP IT FLEXIBLE ENOUGH SO THAT
WE CAN COME BACK AS NECESSARY.
TO ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE COST TO
THE GENERIC THE CAUSES PROGRAM'S
REALLY MINUSCULE --
RECOGNIZING THAT THE THAT THE
PROFIT MARGIN ON GENERICS IS
LESS THAT IT DOES RELATIVELY
IMPACT THEM A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT --
TO LESS THAN HALF A PENNY PER
EVERY PRESCRIPTION --
SO -- AFFAIR
EVERY PRESCRIPTION DOLLAR I
SHOULD SAY SO IT'S IT'S A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT BUT WE WERE TRYING
TO GET THE MANUFACTURERS AND THE
THE WHOLE PRODUCTION LINE. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ONLY.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO THESE
MEDICATIONS IN THESE AYE
INSTRUMENTS THEY HAVE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY WHEN THEY'VE GOT
A WHEN THEY'RE DONE WITH THEIR
USEFUL LIFE BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THEM
AND THEY ARE DANGER.
ALRIGHT WELL I IT LIKE LIKE
EVERYONE'S BEEN SAYING I I THINK
THE KEY HERE --
THE IS THAT WE ARE MOVING GO.
YOU'RE GETTING OUT THE GATE AND
AND WITH WITH PERHAPS THE
DETAILS.
A TO BE ADDRESSED FOLLOWED
LEGISLATION OR AYE THROUGH THE
REGULATIONS AT THAT WOULD BE
DEVELOPED THROUGH CAL RECYCLE
BUTTA.
I LOOK FORWARD TO A ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES.
SO YOU KNOW MY MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT WE DON'T.
YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM'S GONNA BE
PAID.
FOR BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
DETAILS.
ARM ON WHO HAS WHAT BURDEN.
AND THAT'S GOT TO BE WORKED OUT.
COULD YOU SAY A LITTLE BIT MORE
AOUT THAT PROCESS SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
WELL I THINK AT THIS POINT I
WOULD LIKE TO CALL UPON IN TERMS
OF THE PROCESS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT I'VE GOT IT RIGHT UP AND WE
ARE LOOKING CAL RECYCLE TO
DEVELOP THE PROGRAM.
AND YOU DID YOU WANT TO BRING IN
EXPERT UP WE HAVE.
WITH MR SHUTTLES ARE. TO TALK
ABOUT THIS PROCESS YES WANT TO
MAKE SURE I HAVE IT EXACTLY
RIGHT NO I AGREE.
SO COULD YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
PROCESS BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE.
A MAJOR CONCERN OF THE
OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO DISCUSS.
YEAH AND THAT I OBVIOUSLY MAKE
ROOM FOR THE INDUSTRY A MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WHAT.
SOME UNDERSTANDING PERIOD POINT
BLANK THERE'S NO COST ALLOCATION
IN THE BILL IT IS LEFT UP TO
PRIVATE CONTRACT BETWEEN THE
INTERESTED PARTIES.
THEY CAN EITHER GET TOGETHER UP
AND MAKE A DECISION ABOUT HOW
THAT WORKS OR THEY CAN --
THERE'S ROOM FOR THEM TO COMPLY
THEM INDIVIDUALLY --
THERE IS EXISTING PRECEDENT
BECAUSE OF THE PP SWG WHICH A
ó WAY PT SWG US UP THAT
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP WITH. TO THE
LETTER THE OTHER IF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS YOUR
CHIP WORKING GROUP BERENGER AND
THAT YOU TOGETHER WE FIGURE THAT
OUT.
UP IN MY UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
OCCURRED THERE --
IS THAT THERE IS AN INDEPENDENT
PROCESS THAT INCLUDED AYE I
BELIEVE AND AGAIN I'LL DEFER TO
THE INDUSTRY OR ANYBODY ELSE WHO
KNOWS IN MORE DETAIL.
UP THAT INCLUDED AN INDEPENDENT
KIND OF ALMOST AN ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE AND EVERYBODY
PRESENTED THEIR CASE ON WHAT THE
COST ALLOCATION SHOULD BE --
SO ALL THE COMPANIES AS WE WOULD
SUSPECT GOT TOGETHER WITH THEIR
LAWYERS AND FIGURE IT OUT.
I DAY HAVEN'T FIGURED IT OUT YET
OR WELL THAT THE PPS TO BG
OPERATES ALL THE LOCAL PROGRAMS.
THE NINE EXISTING AND YES THERE
IS AN EXISTING COST ALLOCATION
THAT WAS DONE.
ON THROUGH AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE COMPANIES.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA WHETHER
THAT'LL BE THE SAME AGREEMENT
WHEN WE GO TO THE STATE WHY
PROCESS.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE. TO
ANSWER THE FIRST ONE OF THE
THINGS WE SHIED AWAY FROM IN
THIS BILL WAS CHANGING THAT
ALLOCATION MODEL AND LEADING THE
INDUSTRY DETERMINE ON THEIR OWN.
HOW THAT SHOULD BE DONE SO IT IT
IT IT COULD BE CHANGED?
THE BILL ASIDE THE BILL IS
SILENT SO IF PEOPLE.
SO THERE'S NINE PROGRAMS NOW
ENDING NOW A STATEWIDE PROGRAM
THAT COULD BE NEW NEGOTIATIONS
ON THE STATE WIDE PROGRAM.
THEN YOU HAVE A CONCERN I NOW.
OR JUST A LITTLE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION PP SWG WAS SET UP TO
DEAL WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AND THEIR THE ONES WHO OPERATE
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND AS YOU'VE
RECOGNIZED THERE ARE CONCERNS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY IT IS OR HAS IT
ALL AS ITS CONTINUE. TO TO TAKE
BACK AROUND AROUND THE NATION
AND AND COUNTIES UP.
I HAVE CONTINUE --
TO BE IMPLEMENTED PP SWG HAS
GROWN BUT IT IS A BOARD THAT'S
LARGELY DOMINATED BY THE BRAND
FROM CYNICAL COMPANIES --
AND PART OF THAT YES AS A AS I
SAID EARLY ON THE GENERICS DID
PARTICIPATE.
IN SOME OF THE FORMATION BUT
AGAIN THAT WAS.
TO DEVELOPED WITH THE IDEA THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY AT THE TIME AND IT'S IT'S
GROWN WE WE DON'T KNOW IF PP SWG
IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO GROW WITH IT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL BE
THE ONE ENTITY OR WE DON'T KNOW
IF EACH INDIVIDUAL MANUFACTURERS
GOING TO HAVE TO COME UP WITH
ITS OWN PROGRAM.
AND MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE
STATE WHICH IS WHAT LEADS TO
SOME OF THE REAL COST CONCERNS
IN THE BILL FOR GENERIC
MANUFACTURERS.
AND THAT IS SENATOR JACKSON
MENTION.
SOME OF THIS WHETHER IT'S A HALF
A CENT PER PRESCRIPTION.
GENERIC SERB PER DOLLAR WELL A
PER DOLLAR CHECK OUT THE PER TEN
DOLLARS ACCORDING TO THE
STIPULATIONS OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY ORDINANCE IT'S HALF A
CENT PER TEN DOLLARS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GENERICS ARE OFTEN PRICED AT
OPINION PILL [inaudible]
PERIOD [inaudible]
AND GENERIC SURVIVE BASED ON
VOLUME.
AND THE NUMBER OF OF PILLS AND
AND IS THAT THAT ARE BEING
PRESCRIBED THEY DON'T MAKE LARGE
MARGINS ON ANY OF THESE
PRESCRIPTIONS SO I WILL SAY
THOUGH THAT.
IT IS BASED UPON.
PRICE IS THAT THE ACTUAL PRICE
OF THE PRICE THAT THE PERSON
PAIN AT THE COUNTER SET.
WHICH PRICES IT.
I HAVE SAID PRETEND DOLLARS I'M
JUST TELLING YOU IT WAS
STIPULATED IN THE FORMAT LAWSUIT
AGAINST ALAMEDA COUNTY WAS THE
BASS STIPULATED THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM WAS HALF A CENT PER TEN
DOLLARS I'M NOT SURE BEYOND THAT.
I CAN DO WELL IS THAT YOU THE
ACTUAL COURT DOCUMENT NO BUT IS
THAT THE ACTUAL COST OF THE DRUG
OR WHAT THE CONSUMER PAYS WITH
INSURANCE.
I'M NOT I'M NOT CLEAR ALRIGHT.
IF SOMEBODY KNOWS [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALRIGHT THEN THE WHOLESALER
WOULD YOU REPRESENTATIVE DO YOU
WANT TO SAY SOMETHING HERE NOW
OKAY.
OUR YOU DO WE HAVE ANOTHER
EXPERT [inaudible]
NOW.
THE COMPANY IT'S ABOUT THE
ALAMEDA COURT CASE.
IT IT A MIGHTY SANBORN WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL CAN AND THE THE DRUG
COMPANIES STIPULATED TO THE FACT
THAT.
LESS THAN A PENNY FOR EVERY TEN
DOLLARS SOLD IS WHAT THE ENTIRE
PROGRAM WOULD COST FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY SOLD.
HE SAT WITH THE CONSUMERS PAIN
OR IS THAT THE ACTUAL COST OF
THE MEDICATION THE CONSUMERS
PRICE PLUS WHAT INSURANCE PAYS.
THAT IS THE ACTUAL COSTS THAT
THE DRUG COMPANIES WOULD PAY
EXTRA.
THEY'VE INTERNALIZED INTERNAL
BUT BASED UPON WHICH PRICE TO
RUN THE CONSUMER PAYS TO THE ONE
THE CONSUMER PLUS THE INSURANCE
COMPANY PAYS FOR THE LIST PRICE
OF THE DRUG.
WHAT PRICE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
I'D HAVE TO GO BACK AND CHECK I
DON'T THINK I OKAY SO WE DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT LET'S TRY
AND GET AN ANSWER BEFORE IT
COMES TO THE FLOOR?
IF I MAY GENERIC MANUFACTURERS
AND A. M. WAS NOT PARTY TO THOSE
THAT LAWSUIT OR OKAY I
UNDERSTAND.
ALRIGHT -- I
THINK WE'VE GONE THIS FAR AND
THAT IS WE CAN --
YES I GREE WE NEED TO GET TO
WATCH --
THANK GOD I'LL BE BRIEF AND
CLOSING.
PART OF THE BEAUTY OF THIS AS WE
SAID WE SHUT OUT THE PARAMETERS
AND WE SAID TO THE INDUSTRIES
YOU FIGURE OUT HOW YOU WANT TO
PAY FOR THIS.
THAT'S PART OF THE BILL THE
BEAUTY OF THE PROGRAM WHERE THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE REQUIRING TO YOU
DO.
YOU COME TOGETHER YOU FIGURE OUT
HOW YOU WANT TO MAKE THIS WORK
SO GENERICS IN ANY OF THE
PARTIES CONCERNED UP THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENT PLAN UNDER THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW THAT WE KEEP HEARING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE TRYING TO STIFLE
COMPANIES AND OVER REGULATE THEM
HERE WHICH IS SETTING THE
PARAMETERS AND SAYING YOU FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AND
WITH THAT.
I WOULD DIE OFF A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT WILL GET
YOU THE ANSWER TO THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE THOUGH IS THE PRICE
OF THIS THE OF THE TAKE BACK
PROGRAMS IS MINUSCULE.
COMPARED TO THE PROFITS OF THESE
COMPANIES MAKE AND TO PROVIDE A
COMPARATIVE THE AMOUNT THAT'S
OUT THERE AND ALSO COMPARED TO
THE COST WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
COME TO EMERGENCY ROOMS.
BECAUSE THEY'VE MISUNDERSTOOD
THERE MIGHT THINK IT TOO MANY
MEDICATIONS IN THEIR OF MEDICINE
CABINETS THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
GO TO THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
TO RID REMOVE THEIR DRUGS --
OR TO HAVE THEIR SHARPS OF GOT
TO DO SOMETHING THE CLEAN THIS
UP THIS BILL HAS UP A WIDE BERTH
THE SUPPORT WE'VE WORKED REALLY
HARD ON IT.
IF WE NEED TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS GOING FORWARD I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THAT DESIRE INCOME
AND CERTAINLY THE COMMITMENT TO
DO SO WITH THAT I'D ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE OKAY SO I'M VERY MUCH
RECOMMENDED AN AYE VOTE.
WE NEED TO GET THIS TO THE FLOOR
WE CANNOT LIVE WITH. FORTY FIFTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WHATEVER MORE
NUMBER NUMBER IF YOU DON'T DO
THIS YEAH EXACTLY INCLUDING THE
CITY AT THE COUNTY OF LA WHICH
IS A QUARTER OF THE POPULATION
THE STATE THIS NEEDS TO GO.
FORWARD I DO RESPECT THE
CONCERNS OF THE WHOLESALERS IN
THE GENERIC DRUGS.
AND I AM WILLING TO HOLD A
HEARING ON THIS --
EARLY NEXT YEAR FINDING OUT HOW
THE COST STOCK ALLOCATION IS
DONE --
HEARING FROM OUR MEMBERS AND
OTHERS I THINK THIS IS OUR I AM
VERY GLAD YOU RAISED THIS ISSUE
AND I PROMISE YOU WE WILL FOLLOW
UP ON IT.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS SB TWO TWELVE JACKSON
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S NOT VOTING KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
I'M GLAD.
ARAMBULA AYE AYE BRO.
GROWING UP VOTING [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MORE OUT TO CHEAT WHAT'S RICHIE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
I WILL HOLD THIS OPEN FOR MISTER
HOLDEN FOR A FEW MINUTES.
SAY TELL LA [inaudible]
ONE THIRTY EUREKA.
PROBABLY IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
YES NO WE WILL WE WILL HOLD A
HEARING THIS IS JOSH.
MAKE SURE YOU.
YEAH WELL MAKE SURE YOU SEE YA.
WE'RE TRYING TO SET SOMETHING UP
NEXT YEAR.
WITH A HAND THIS MICROPHONE ON
ALRIGHT MISTER HOLDEN HOW DO YOU
VOTE.
I FOR MISTER HOLDEN THAT'S FIVE
ICE FAMILIES OUT.
THE MEETING IS OVER THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH